hey leute was gedacht und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
wir sind hier gerade schon losgefahren
eigentlich wollte ich eben schon laufen
habe ich aber vergessen und zwar heute
mal ein komplett anderes video so was
gab es auch noch nie von mir
wir wollen ja in köln und nicht weit von
uns ist so ein braunkohleabbau man das
ding ist halt hier wurde so ein ganzes
dorf umgesiedelt einfach weil diese
stadt die oder dieser ortsteil auch noch
vom braunkohleabbau gefallen ist das
heißt irgendwann wird da auch komplett
alles vernichtet und deswegen wurden
irgendwie alle leute die dir an der
stadt wohnen umgesiedelt und da ist
jetzt halt so eine art geisterstadt hat
das mal gehört von freunden von uns und
die meinten dass es echt interessant das
kann man sich auf jeden fall mal
angucken und wir haben uns jetzt spontan
gesagt das machen wir doch einfach mal
so wir haben jetzt nach pause gemacht
weil hier ist noch so ein schild steht
halt drauf dass man die ganzen häuser
und so nicht betreten darf ist ja auch
irgendwie logisch und wie das hier alles
abläuft und was da passiert als ich
würde sagen wir fahren einfach mal
dadurch und gucken uns dass man keine
ahnung wie fern ich da jetzt gut was
film kann aber ich bin echt schon
neugierig und ja ich nehme euch mit juli
ist auch dabei die sonne geht auch
gerade passend unter wir wollten ein
paar coole fotos auch noch machen also
leute ganz wichtiger bevor es losgeht
also eigentlich hatten wir geplant
natürlich auch noch ein paar aufnahmen
mehr zu machen gerade vom boden aus
vielleicht noch ein bisschen dadurch zu
laufen ihr werdet es am ende des videos
sehen wir wurden dann halt irgendwie von
der security weggeschickt die haben da
so eine security einfach weil da viele
touristen kommen und sich das einfach
mal anschauen wollen das ist ja an sich
auch mittlerweile privatbesitz also
gehört nach viermal somit darf man da
halt irgendwie nur bis 17 uhr umlaufen
das wusste ja nicht wir haben trotzdem
das bestmögliche herausgeholt was man
für ein konto hat mir auch eine drohne
dabei und ja deswegen wundert euch nicht
wenn ihr halt so wenig aufnahmen von
betritt tut mir auch sehr leid ich habe
überlegt ob sich das überhaupt lohnt
hochzuladen aber hier ist es jetzt
einfach für mich weil ich ganz
interessant interessanter ort und ja
viel spaß mit dem video
ist er wirklich jeder kommen noch ein
autounfall stirbt ihr auch gedreht oder
das dadurch gefahren
der bauch gedreht
aber hier ist ein auto
aber die häuser alle verlassen oder hier
nicht eigentlich können wir doch jetzt
nicht widerfahren verstummt
haben wir denn hier machen pokémon
vermerken sie mit jetzt ende würde es
einen hohen druck in die luft nach
geistern
da aber der stoff ist das dorf ja übels
klein wird hier gibt es einfach so einen
star wars tage heißt geisterstadt
immerath also ich habe jetzt gerade mal
geparkt wir haben auch keine ahnung wie
groß das ist ob das jetzt schon alles
ist da hinten sind auch noch häuser da
geht gerade schön die sonne unter und
hier kann man auch noch so leicht häuser
sehen kleines hexenhaus also ich lag hat
noch kurz mein handy dann würde ich
einfach mal die drohne starten weil
keine ahnung so hier sind komplett
überall die rollladen runter hier ist
gar nichts außer die seine auswahl aber
das sieht mehr so aus als wäre das von
irgendeinem arbeiter also jedoch leben
zu wollen auf keinen fall denn bevor der
fährt gerade einer weg wir dachten jetzt
wird die police nicht weil ich weiß
nicht ob er noch hinter mir widerfährt
weg in kriminelle balda so leute mal
sehen was wir jetzt hier schon von oben
erfassen können
[Musik]
rico
hier sind das ja gerade auf der rhone
420 das weiß ich sagte immer komplett
nach oben
wie weit kann die hoch also hier unten
sind
ich würde jetzt einfach mal ganz locker
lässig über die häuser da fliegen lassen
seliger nicht mehr der kamera man sieht
hier einfach gar nicht mehr die sitzt da
und da sind auch das sind autos und so
[Musik]
und hier geht es noch weiter weiß dann
wenn man da hochfährt
wir sind ja voll viele autos aber das
glaube ich ein schrottplatz oder so ich
geh mal runter
[Musik]
es ist irgendwie dass sie das selber tun
aber jetzt ist auf jeden fall schon
und siehst du was
[Musik]
gärtner
da ist ein weg
aber sie ist so etwas gewohnt ist oder
nicht nämlich sagen man kann es am pc
wahrscheinlich besser sehen darf ich mal
hast du vorne was gesehenes gewohnt da
kann ich dann mein leben war das ein
film an der donau und das macht den
größten so leute juli fliegt jetzt noch
dahin ist ein geisterhaus oder was auch
immer das ist
was ist wo sie das gruselig aus alten
wir dahin gehen zu fuß
da haben wir hier geboren auf dem hof
keiner kann es runter gehen ihr seht ja
durch den thron shots ja aber nicht
landen
junge
jetzt gleich kommt gary face dabei da
steht sex also es ist echt aufregend
[Musik]
aber dann
das sind häuser oder davon gehabt
womit wir dann da lang machen dass er
wieder aufgenommen
sehen die das für mich kurz noch mal
runter jetzt wollen wir gerade
weggeschickt oder sind securitys
gekommen ihm halten wir sollten schnell
weg sonst müsste jetzt richtig teuer
wenn die polizei hier hinkommen so keine
aber die meinten ja anzeige 60 euro
sowieso und dann noch keine ahnung was
noch aber das stand doch gar nicht auf
den schildern immobilie nicht gelesen
aber wir haben die uns hingesehen
das ist also meiner meinung nach ist
dieses auto was die ganze zeit da war
das kann das auch nicht eben hat es auch
immer noch mal hier drauf
ich wurde ein bisschen nachts allein
unterwegs hier wurde noch wer da wurde
nachher aber wir sind da ist auch jemand
drin das licht gebrannt will sind noch
wohnen wenn man hier jetzt rein fährt
hier standen nämlich heben und dann
haben die uns gesehen wenn man hier hoch
fährt kann man hier wohl raus machen
ich fand das gar nicht riskieren ich
würde da wieder raus fahren hier hoch
würde mich noch mehr häuser weil wir
haben patronen aufnahmen gemacht ich
werde das ja zu hause sehen wir auch
niemanden hier gestört oder so wir waren
da vorsichtig fahren ist natürlich noch
kein und vielleicht können ja einige von
euch hier diese in diesem ortsteil jetzt
kann ein gefallen wenn ihr irgendwelche
orte kennt in der nähe von köln schreibt
jedoch einfach mal rein in die
kommentare dann können wir den fall
wollen wir nicht noch mal die aus alten
geist zogen mit so einer app erlassen
geist zunächst mal ernsthaft also wenn
ihr noch ein ort kennt in der nähe von
köln schreibt dann gerne mal die
kommentare da machen wir dann gut
herr otto stumpf das ist ein bis 17 uhr
geht s wo ist da der sinn der wohnung
auf die leute eine öffentliche straße
heute das war's mit dem video das nach
oben wenn der bock hat das war nochmal
irgendwo hinfahren als luftkurort wird
hier enden in der umgebung und wir sehen
uns werden auch abonniert auch gerne
juli auf untergang der juli